hey guys Mary here I'm at the Seattle
indie booth this is outside of packs
show on Monday and I'm hanging out with
my friend Ezra Hanson white and he made
a pretty interesting game called memory
of a broken dimension right away you can
kind of see it's a different looking
game it's pretty cool and I'd like to
hear more about it so this game is it's
the first-person exploration game
basically
but the game is themed is a emulator of
a fictional computer system and so the
players role in the game is they're just
kind of playing as themselves at their
keyboard or you know control pad and
they're figuring out how to use this
computer system and when during this
first personhood the environment is
really glitched out and there's broken
geometry one of the main mechanics is
that you trying to go around and rebuild
the environment um so right now I'm just
I'm finding kind of the right
perspective viewpoint and then it makes
it optic solid so now I could walk
across it to progress further in the
environment
and then another thing so this is all
work in progress but this little
floating icon is kind of moving around
and I'm directing it right now and it's
actually scanning the environment so
when you can't see stuff you can send
the probe over that way and it'll scan
the environment and it's building out a
world map so the further the player
progresses in the game the more of this
world they've built out and they're
finding items and things in the
environment which might give them more
abilities or introduced more tools and
programs in the computer system so you
know still in progress I'm kind of
figuring out a bit as I go for a demo
though I mean it it visually already
looks incredibly interesting there's a
lot of detail that you can put into this
this first demo yes so the this actually
this build i started earlier this year
i've been working full-time on it
originally this project was kind of like
a side project and i would come home
from work and work on it occasionally it
but in order to actually finish it I
decided that I sort of just have to go
full time on it so I used a bit of money
that I had saved up specifically for it
and now I'm like doing it for real so
this this demo that I've been showing
today is like it's really focused on
just showing the environment and the
visuals because I've been trying to
figure out you know how I'm going to
build the rest of the content in the
game and stuff like that well so you can
see already as you're exploring this
world and trying to create more area for
you to walk on that it kinda has like
almost like an MC Escher look to it it
looks like you can get lost pretty
easily that's something that you kind of
want to invoke exploration in the player
yeah it's so it's purposely purposely
very confusing the kind of neat thing
though is like as you progress in the
environment like it it's more clear so
these past areas that I've been going
through or now they're all clear and
more viewable so that sort of serves a
role later in the game like the more
that you have the world built out it'll
allow you to do more things I don't want
to like reveal too much
yes it's definitely purposely supposed
to like screw the players vision and you
know make them really kind of figure out
what they're seeing currently this looks
like the main mechanic is to kind of see
things from the right angle and kind of
solve the puzzle through visual
exploration are there any other
mechanics that people will be expecting
later on in the game or is this like the
main main ish well I guess I wouldn't
call it the main mechanic right now but
it is sort of the one that is like most
prominent in this level but there's yeah
there'll be other other abilities like
but the funny thing is like right now I
can't jump in the demo but I've been
working on prototyping like a teleport
mechanic for the player so I sort of as
a player uncovers more of the world like
I want them to become more adept at like
traversing through the environment and
they'll be doing more things showing up
in the environment and the objects that
show up in the environment kind of show
up is icons on your desktop so your
your computer system is almost like
downloading things just as you're
playing through the environment so I'm
kind of just toying with like just
general computer concepts and sort of
trying to like make the experience like
the first time you're using a computer
like if you've never used a computer
before and you're like no nothing about
it that's sort of like what I'm trying
to get at based on when I was yeah when
I first used computers when I was
younger it seemed very mysterious I want
the the game to seem very mysterious
also that's awesome and where can people
find out more information on this game
right now the main website is broken
dimension comm and I'm hoping to start a
steam greenlight campaign later this
month thanks a lot
you